hello and welcome to another video today
we're going to talk about knights and
magic kurata a company programmer and a
mecca model fan is killed in a car
accident he's reincarnated as a young
boy named eru in the fremay villa
kingdom a world where magic exists after
witnessing his father defeating a demon
beast in mech called sidoo at night aru
is motivated to be a silhouette knight
pilot so he too can ride one as well
during his magic training he befriends
the twins adi and kid and also teaches
them his magic skills when the trio
finally enroll at the academy directed
by eru's grandfather eru learns that he
can't pilot a silhouette night as he's
too young and short but is allowed to
skip to middle school classes after
impressing his teachers with his power
as eru becomes 12 years old he joins a
class training trip between the middle
and high school students at forest and
meet stefania the twin's older
half-sister later that night the class
camp is attacked by a swarm of demon
beasts eru adi and kid rescue stephanie
and the rest of the students with the
help of their high school seniors riding
sidhu at night elsewhere a surviving
silhouette knight battles a giant demon
beast tortoise called behemoth it
attacks the gates of the forest where
the guards die fighting it as one runs
to the capital to request the knights
for help back at the students camp eru
realizes something big must have scared
the demon beasts into going to their
camp and witnessed the behemoth
appearing as the students evacuate the
senior students silhouette knights led
by edgar helvey and daedric fight and
distract the behemoth after seeing one
of his comrades killed by the behemoth's
fire breath daedric runs away in fear
eru follows him knocks him out and
steals his silo at night after
improvising the silhouette knight's
controls and improving its movements
using his magic and programming aero
rides into battle and rescues his
seniors by stabbing the behemoth's left
eye with a sword despite help from the
kingdom's silhouette knights the
behemoth is too strong due to its thick
arm and fire breath so in order to
defeat it aero jumps onto the behemoth's
head and casts lightning into its
wounded eye which transmits to its brain
killing it at sunrise surviving night
runners are shocked to discover the
silhouette knight's pilot was aru having
a fun experience riding a silhouette
night eru tells his friends that he
plans to make a custom silhouette night
for himself meanwhile the king of
fremoville takes an interest with aru
due to his deeds
eru is summoned by the king who wants to
reward him any prize for defeating the
behemoth much of his grandfather shock
eru asks for the classified schematics
of an ether reactor the heart of a
silhouette knight when arrow explains he
wants to make his dream silhouette
knight and ride as his hobby the king's
amused with his answer and agrees to
aero's request if he can build an
improved silhouette knight first one of
the king's advisers tells the twins to
report to him if aru is successful so he
may inform the king meanwhile aru
explains his plan to improve a
silhouette knight's performance to his
dwarf friend batson and his senior and
silhouette knight engineer david who's
impressed with eru's idea using helve
silhouette night as a test bed eru and
the dwarven engineers improved the
thrandorki's strength by 30 percent and
had sidearms armed with magic rods
behind its back so the silhouette knight
can fight close range and car spells at
the same time in the meantime eru and
batson also build silhouette gears
human-sized mech suits so that adi and
kid can learn how to operate silhouette
knights with the improvements done the
trandorches now renamed telestyle
performs well in its first test run
later helvey's telestyle battles edgar's
silhouette knight in a mock match and
almost wins before the telestyle mana
runs out later that night the engineers
celebrate the telestyle success and eru
thinks of more silhouette night ideas
unaware that another group is spying on
their work
while aru and the engineers trying to
find a way to fix the telestyle's high
mana consumption eru also builds weapons
for the silhouette gears including an
automatic crossbow addie and kid report
to their father about the telestyle's
performance which he in turns informs
marquis dix guard under the marquis
orders the order of the scarlet rabbit
was three telestar silhouette knights
brought to four casa juices where the
marquis will inspect and test the
knights personally during the journey
the scarlet rabbit convoy is ambushed by
a shaker worm demon beast which edgar
helvey and daytrick in their telestyles
are able to defeat this impresses knight
commander of the scarlet rabbit unaware
by everyone the ambush was set up by
order of the bronze fang the spies who
have been observing eyru's work at the
fort marquis who dislikes aru for
breaking the status quo on knight design
meets eru personally after telling eru
that he'll be reporting all new
silhouette knight designs to the king
the marquis is flabbergasted the area is
not interested with fame or riches since
he wants to make newer and better
silhouette knights and eventually
relents as aru's friends head to fort to
get him the order of the bronze fan
causes a demon beast attack at a nearby
village to lure out the order of the
scarlet rabbit so they can attack the
fort edgar and dietrich accompany batson
david kid and addie in their silhouette
knights to the fort meanwhile lady karen
lit and the bronze fang knights managed
to sneak into fort and hijack the fort
silhouette knights including the three
telestyles despite the commander and the
scarlet rabbit knights attempts to stop
them lady currently and two of her
subordinates escaped the fort with two
of the telestars however the bronze fang
knights encounter edgar and daytrik on
the way which the latter two tried to
stop them with kid and addie helping in
their silhouette gears upon learning
from batson and david and what happened
to the stolen telestyles aero wears a
silhouette gear and helps commander
defeat the intruders in the fort
elsewhere daytrick kid and addie managed
to defeat lady curled its subordinates
while she herself defeats edgar and
escapes daedric tries to follow her but
he and the others are surrounded by
demon beasts until aru and the commander
arrive to help them the next morning the
marquis is shocked to discover the
intruders that attacked the fort and
stole the telestyle were using a
forbidden concoction that attracts demon
beasts and turns them crazy concluding
this was the work of another nation days
later aru and his friends are thanked by
the king for their work who also created
a new order of knights called the order
of the silver phoenix led by aru to
research and create better silhouette
nights
as a telestyle is sent to the silhouette
knight laboratory the director hopes to
reverse engineer it and make their own
mass produce silhouette knights to
impress the king aero and the order of
the silver phoenix begin their work on
creating newer and improved silhouette
knights with help from the marquis who
delivers two silhouette knight caldatos
as base models later nora and the order
of the azure hawk capture the spies who
help the bronze fang knights and prevent
any more leaks of information from the
academy aero creates silhouette gears
for the nightsmith to ease their
workload and use silhouette knight
designs and improvements to be added
after creating a two-seater cockpit for
addy and kidd a silhouette knight shaped
like a centaur uses magical daggers as
keys to start a silhouette night to
prevent another hijacking attempt arrow
in the order of the silver phoenix head
to the capital to face the silhouette
knight laboratories galdato models in
front of king and his ministers the
match between the order of silver
phoenix and the laboratory team ends in
a draw as with the new units increased
power they reached a stalemate against
units less advanced but with more
experienced pilots some time later aru
and his friends graduate from middle
school to move with the rest of the
order to another fort to dedicate
themselves to silhouette knight
development the king decides to retire
and leave the kingdom to his son he then
approaches eru and asks him to develop
new exclusive silhouette knights for him
and his grandson prince emery's the
order then produces two units with the
same capabilities one silver and the
other gold when both decide to choose
the gold one the king and his grandson
decide to settle it with a jewel with
emery's claiming the victory and the
king accepting the silver one when a
large group of shell-cased beasts head
for the city where the ether reactors
are developed and whereas the home of
the elves the order of silver phoenix is
dispatched to defend it along with the
king and emery's with the power of the
new unit eru with his friends easily
defeats the attackers with aero killing
the shell-cased queen by himself after
the battle the king finally accepts
aru's request to let him learn the
secret of how ether reactors are created
and takes him to the city of alves he
then spends three months there to learn
the process and returns with the king's
permission to use the catalyst of the
behemoth and the shell-cased queen he
killed to create a custom ether reactor
and use it to complete his own personal
silhouette knight ikaruga the zalu deck
kingdom starts a war to conquer the
entire western continent using their
newest models of silhouette knights and
transport airships the forces of zalu
deck easily bypass the defenses of the
kingdom of cush bercha the king requests
a duel with the commander prince
christobal to buy enough time for his
daughter princess elianora to escape the
king loses and is killed but elianora
ends up captured by the enemy forces
along with her aunt martina and cousin
who are also emery's relatives in
response emery's father sends the order
of silver phoenix along with emery's to
investigate the situation and after
easily defeating the enemies guarding
the border they discovered that their
silhouette knights have the same
technology as the telestyle stolen from
fort upon hearing that elianora is being
forced to marry cristobal eru and his
friends start making plans to rescue her
but cristobal sends gustav to track them
down upon meeting eru's party gustav
attacks them but when they prove
themselves too strong for him he
retreats assisted by lady garlic using
special silhouette gears the order of
silver phoenix successfully rescues
elianora martina and elianora's cousin
cristobal sends a party to chase after
them but their pursuers are easily
defeated by ayrus igaruga and forced to
flee once reaching safety eru's party
establishes a base and agrees to provide
the remaining kush perching forces with
upgrades to their silhouette knights in
exchange for the scraps of all enemy
units defeated by them with these new
upgrades the koshberg can easily fend
off an enemy attack on the city lady
carl hit is ordered to launch a surprise
attack on the silver phoenix's base to
recapture the princess in exchange for
having her family's name restored
however errol and his friends were
prepared and easily defeat and capture
the bronze fang knights with lady
girlhood defeated in a battle against
edgar christobart leads a large force of
silhouette knights and airships to crush
the cospercian forces at their
stronghold and capture elianora however
he falls into a trap made by the order
of silver phoenix who now possess
javelin missiles to take down their
airships with his forces routed due to
the silver phoenix's superior silhouette
knight cristobal's airship tries to
escape only to be confronted by the
ikaruga eru easily defeats cristobal in
battle which the latter tries to bribe
eru to join his side but when aru admits
of no interest in nobility cristobal
falls to his death rather than suffer
humiliation of being captured
demoralizing his forces and making them
retreat eleonora becomes queen of
conspiracies and declares the rebirth of
their nation as the combined silver
phoenix and kush bernstein forces retake
their lands zaludex top scientist
promises princess catalina that he'll
build a new weapon to avenge her
brother's death months later the silver
phoenix and cush purchasing forces
finally retake a fortress held by zalu
deck but a giant airship shaped like a
drake attacks them the zylo deck's
newest weapon battles the ikaruga whose
captain donateo wants to avenge
cristobal's death meanwhile azalea deck
force led by doloteo's son gustavo
battles trick in his men but gustavo is
forced to abandon his silhouette night
after daytrick tricks him into
exhausting his mana supply aero is
unable to take down the drake due to his
defenses and is forced to land the
ikaruga after the drake damages its jet
engines the drake is forced to withdraw
after exhausting its mana trying to
destroy the ikaruga as eru and his
allies withdraw prince cristobal
scientist repairs and installs a bigger
ether reactor in the drake to give it
more power and gustavo received the
zaludex royal family silhouette knight
by princess catalina meanwhile after
discussing their battle plans the silver
phoenix and cospercians agreed to
eleanor's strategy where she'll lead the
entire cosplation army to recapture
their capital while eru and the silver
phoenix knight battled the drake as the
cospercians fight the zalu decks at the
last fortress that leads to the capital
the drake arrives with the scientist on
board to attack elianora's position only
to discover eru has repaired and
improved a captured airship to fight
them
after drawing the drake away from the
battlefield aero's party launches an
attack with javelin missiles loaded with
oil that once ignited surround the enemy
ships in flames in response dolotea
activates the drake's dragonblood
reactor that surrounds it with a massive
energy field meanwhile on land an
infiltration party hijacks the
drawbridge controls allowing the
kusperchen forces to invade while
gustavo is defeated by edgar with
emery's help back in the sky aero breaks
through the drake's energy shield and
attacks it directly defeating it in a
last effort dolotea takes control of the
drake and attempts to ram it on the base
camp to kill elianora but arrow and kids
stop him taking down the drake for good
after the battle the conspiring forces
take control of the capital and catalina
poisons herself to death to avoid
capture thus ending the war with zalu
decks defeated and elianora recognized
as kusperch's de facto ruler
back to flemish villa the king commends
the order of silva phoenix for their
efforts and awards aeru with his own
laboratory while the airship technology
is spread along the neighbouring
countries ushering a new era of trade
and transportation across the continent
so this is it for today's video if you
like the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time